This is not even a whole word, but can you guess which language this is?
Of course you can!
All thanks to that very Spanish letter 침.
Wait a second.
Once this one with a lift on it was not as Spanish.
Divide them in two; you will find the story of an ordinary sign that grew into
an extraordinaire letter.
Spain has a national hero.
A very old one.
About 1000 years old.
They call him El Cid.
Or "El Thid"?
See, Spain is notorious for its play, but here in the western hemisphere
and even in Andaluc칤a it is "El Sid".
El Cid did good things, as national heroes are supposed to do.
He used a legendary weapon.
He fought cunningly for various factions, but always kept larger goals in mind.
He won the heart of the mob.
Oh, and he loved Babieca, his trusted steed.
A legend tells us how they met.
When he was young, su padrino, his godfather, took him to choose his own horse.
He was treated to a parade of beautiful stallions.
"Go, choose one.
The very best you see! "
Either way, El Cid peered through all the beautiful moons and caught the eye of the outermost
horse of them all.
"This one.
I want this one."
His godfather couldn't believe it.
"Babieca!
Fool!
Why have they just chosen? "
"Oh, Babieca.
Yes, his name will be Babieca.
He will become a good horse. "
Ah, Spain.
You have spent centuries weaving stories such as these about your beloved Cid.
The most epic of these epic stories is a poem written in the 12th century: Cantar de Mio
Cid, Song of My Cid
Of course there is this older Latin history written closer to the events, but the people, they
love the epic poem.
That poem was in one, rare manuscript.
And if you want to read it, you need to know Old Spanish.
Not just Spanish?
No, Old Spanish.
Different words with different meanings, different spelling and pronunciation, different grammar.
But before you can also start, you will be blocked by the writings of this writer.
The problem is not his writing.
He was a great writer, neat and tidy.
The problem is that this script is not your script.
Yes, it's the Latin alphabet, but even once you've adjusted to the letters, there's something
weird.
Put your nose close enough to sniff the paper.
Actually, the pergamino, parchment.
Close enough to see those little curls.
An interesting fact about the parchment of time.
Writers did not go to the store and got packages for a cent for a page.
This book-making thing was a very expensive undertaking.
Among other things, old writers came up with different ways to save paper
and keep their manuscripts beautiful.
A trick was to make the words shorter.
With hundreds of years of practicing writing, medieval writers had it
a library of symbols.
They can be beautiful, but here is a simple one that you often encounter the titulus.
What is it for?
Look at the letters below.
Sometimes they are short words.
Scribes abbreviated everything from holy names to everyday pronouns.
When they did this, they left a hint so that they knew that an abbreviation was used.
It does have a more specific use.
Look at the words mand칩 "commanded", and also don "gentleman" and donna "wife" of the Latin
dominus and domina.
The writer could write them in full or he could remove a consonant and a titulus
write on top of the previous letter.
And guess which letter was missing?
The nasal "n".
Writing n 'on top of the previous letter instead of on the line is not something we do
CID can accuse.
It was an age-long trend, both for Latin nasals, ns and ms.
Good luck going through medieval manuscripts without the titulus.
N 'above vowels, n' above consonants, everywhere!
But these ns were still optional.
Take the word for "year", annus, who had two n'en next to each other.
That word became the Spanish anno.
As a writing scholar you could remove the second n and put a titulus on the other.
But you could also remove the first n and put a titulus on the a
Or just keep them next to each other.
After a while, those other clues were omitted and 침, the former double n
all alone in Spain.
Apparently the only one.
Why did only this one stay?
Well, it was common.
The other nasal signs were interchangeable with a real n.
But Latin double-n got its own statement: "nj", "e침e"
This remaining titulus is not as lonely as it appears.
Portugal found the same marking system very useful for neighbors.
In Modern Portuguese they still use them, not above n, but to mark the nasal o and a.
칚 - 칫 -침
Oh, and another fact to impress your friends.
The name of this, "titulus", became "tilde", which the English borrowed as
"lifted".
In Spanish, "tilde" does not only mean this thing.
It is the name for a special or diacritical sign.
Also the accents.
But today is not one with a funny piece of fruit on it.
Not in Spanish!
One more change had to be made: a change of image.
The Real Acedemia Espa침ola, Royal Spanish Academy, came together in the early 1700s
to organize and oversee Spanish vocabulary.
(Time for order in this language!)
Their dictionary is the gold standard, but in 1726 the group barely took one
first stitch at this dictionary, with their Diccionario the autoridades.
You will not find the 침 on a page of one of his
6 volumes, but entries starting with 침 are listed separately after n.
It is an initiative of the academy that has already been taken completely.
Today 침 has its own seat in the Spanish alphabet (n칰mero 洧링洧맅!), And it is like that
typically Spanish that it has become a symbol of Spanish culture.
Here, I have marked my channel for Spain and Latin America!
You laugh, but that's how some companies do it.
So what were ordinary markings on parchment in El Cid's days, found a way
to last longer than the others and became a completely Spanish letter, one that only occasionally
seem like a recognizable retrospect of his younger days from relatives from not so distant countries.
Hang on for more linguistic stories and subscribe for language.